Seth is with us in Virginia
hi Seth how are you hi gentlemen good
afternoon so a relatively new listener
so I had a question and wanted some
advice you could help me in regards to
my wife's student loan her student loans
are roughly about 190,000 good Lord and
it's an income based repayment plan
where I don't know what what is she a
doctor or a lawyer she's actually she
has her master's in social work um
$200,000 yeah yeah and what does she
make a year well that's the thing she
didn't say who mom for the last seven
years with our kids and she's slowly
kind of getting back into work and my
plan has always been to you know allow
her to start working and basically take
all the income that she would make from
whatever job she has and put that
towards the loan
what is your household what do you make
I'll make about 175 a year okay no I
would not do that I would just pay them
I just pay the loan off now you make out
into seventy five thousand dollars a
year let's get this mess cleaned up this
is your wife for better for worse for
richer for poorer in sickness and in
health
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
it says in the old the old wedding vows
in the Book of Common Prayer they don't
say that anymore but that's that was the
old days and so that's what you did it's
not hervana now I know it's got our name
on it and technically it is her loan
but I'm saying relationally and
everything else you make $175,000 a year
this is hanging around your awesome neck
and income based repayment is just gonna
drag it out for 40 freaking years mm-hmm
knock it in the head be done with it in
about two years hundred thousand dollars
a year for two years of clean this mess
up yeah good that's great I mean you
know what they I get robbed
when I hear that because stealing if she
hadn't married him she'd be screwed oh
yeah she's working two jobs trying to
make payments and it's just you know
people have sold the bill of goods that
you've got to go to some fancy school
you gotta go to this high price
University if you're gonna make anything
of yourselves and again people hear me
we did the largest study of millionaires
that's ever been done talked over 10,000
of them okay over 10,000 and it was
unbelievable because 62% of them went to
public state universities these are
people that are millionaires eight
percent went to Community College so you
do not have to go to a hundred thousand
dollar-a-year private school in order to
be able to have and build wealth gosh
well a good news is that Seth you guys
are in a position to clean this up and
so our recommendation will be to clean
it up very very quickly now then the
sidebar is for everyone listening if
you're going to get a degree in
something before you spend money to get
a degree before you spend a dollar to
get a degree find out what that field of
study pays yes and if you're gonna be a
$40,000 your social worker
don't go $200,000 in debt to get that
degree because that's mathematically
unpalatable it mate in other words a
Kittel throw up in the back of your
mouth when you start talking about that
kind of number and so it's just the
return it doesn't work no the Social
Work is a you know unknown oh yeah good
profession and it is a good thing to
help families and hold them together and
that kind of thing but you not when
yours is falling apart and so good news
is in Seth's case that they can clean it
up very very quickly and he's a new
listener and he's trying to guide his
way through this but you've got this
great income dude if I'm you I'm just
gonna punch this thing in the nose and
knock it out the rest of you get Anthony
O'Neill's book that free degree and and
figure out a way to go to school and
study something that the income based on
what you study makes sense based on what
you spent to get the degree mm-hmm so
don't become a professional in the spin
jury
whole professional life paying off your
degree no you're right Dave but you
mentioned this that's I mean I'm
thinking back if you've got somebody
that was single and he's dating someone
can you imagine this shock if you've
never talked about money together and
all of a sudden you find out they've got
two three hundred thousand and student
loan debt yeah and you know it's so
normal now there's no thinking thing
about it but you know and again he
obviously has a wonderful career yes
it's making a lot of money so that that
probably came into the decision-making
time it would make sense that it does
and it's all fair that's all fair but
parents um and and for those of you that
are raised by wolves or something listen
up do not you know really think about
what your return on investment is on
education it all education is not bad
but all education is not worth the money
that's right
and some of it isn't worth the money all
right because it mathematically it's an
it's not a it's not a matter it's not a
moral call and none judgment calls not
like Oh what what is too expensive let
me tell you what too expensive it's too
expensive is when you pay out a
gazillion dollars more than you're ever
gonna get back oh that's too expensive
that's right or then you'll get back as
a result of your choice right then
that's too expensive you can't do it so
it's not a matter of it's two hundred
thousand dollars I'm morally wrong no
it's not it's not at all is it you know
but but it's not it doesn't make good
it's not logical that's right do that
especially if you're paying cash for it
you wouldn't do it
no you wouldn't for a forty thousand
dollar job
learn to count we're always gonna have a
job this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]